hey guys how's it going so today the
whole fam is loaded up here in this
wonderful rental that we got we are
heading to go to a shoot with Snoop Dogg
well the family I mean they're attending
because I really wanted them to meet
Snoop I'm not really under percent sure
what I'm doing I think I'm gonna be
asking him some footer questions or
something like that for the YouTube show
but yeah this is gonna be great
snoops a big Steelers fan fans loaded up
I got my Terrible Towel brought the dog
it's gonna be great
he we did bring you Steeler shirt so
we'll see he's a little wild today so
I'm not sure he's exceptionally wild
today though this is your second shoot
here Maddie aren't you excited I forget
why I was here last time with her I
remember but it's great now we have to
go in this way come on Maddie let's go
buddy being a good boy such a good boy
like always
not really I know as brands like he's
tugging her along
this is a laundry Oh
we just got done doing this shoot with
snoop we're now at Home Depot because
you know I don't know if you guys know
or not I mean oh not to say that like
women can't fix things but I don't
actively go around my house looking to
fix things or you know I actually don't
have any tools my apples my dad like you
have to get some tools you need some
things you know like common things like
a screwdriver and a hammer and stuff
like that I don't have any of it so
we're here he's gonna help me out and
then he's probably gonna fix all the
things in my house that need fixed I
thought my furniture I don't like I
can't get cable I built my stuff too I
just don't like it I don't like it
either but sometimes you have to do
things you don't like to see yeah well I
do
okay I'm a strong independent woman you
don't need no man sometimes I do I took
more than usual
maybe I just need Jenna to come over now
what really your battery really is gonna
die yeah it really is gonna die so
we will tell them deeper once we make
keys and then none of them worked
thousands of your apartment I was in
Pittsburgh I think I might get a
flashlight
that's a big tub get in there Danny's
hub Oh
it says please do not get in the top
quiet imagine it was complete some
candidates up he's not sure do something
crazy video
she doesn't hug people say do you think
you like that there's mommy I wonder
what kind of things that they're getting
for me getting a drill a drill right I
don't know I think I'm gonna get a
bucket
you don't need a bucket do not love it
why not one of these days you're gonna
be like oh my gosh we're in a dire
situation and we need a bucket yes we're
getting this bucket this bucket is gonna
come in handy one day
cause the bucket challenge what's that
the bucket challenge are you may not you
know is that something like yeah I've
only done the ice bucket challenge I
actually don't know okay look how
festive this is how beautiful shiny
Shamu dad should I get did you get me a
hammer
maybe this Brian actually got me a
tomahawk for Christmas one year and I
don't think he realized that it was a
real tomahawk yeah I was I remember a
thing
where is perfect I'm getting a bucket
telling you this bucket is gonna come in
handy one day it's gonna come in handy
are you making a movie are you making a
movie
are you picking them feel free without
any - I'm totally okay with it you're
like I want to be a quality drill you
know what I'm like wrong I don't the
only brand I recognize is the wall looks
upon though I think that looks nice the
wall this is just too much for me thank
you I'm I needed some duct tape Billy
just seen do you have insert anything
I'm like no I don't have that
nope do you have no dahhh i might have
that the dog knows what he likes he was
really bad today we were walking on
indeed Oh Monica and we wouldn't be
Apple Store and he was just walking and
just took the biggest in Apple